Einstein's declaration that the speed of
light is constant
well that's perhaps the most famous of
all scientific sentences but what does
it actually mean right speed of light
being constant well to explain that let
me first use an example without light
something more familiar like a baseball
so imagine I've got a baseball on my
hand right here and I can throw it
towards you at say a hundred miles an
hour
that's a bit of a stretch but stay with
me now if you're standing still then the
ball is going to whisk by you at a
hundred miles per hour
but if you say run away from me as I'm
throwing that ball toward you run away
say at five miles an hour the ball will
approach you less quickly at 95 miles an
hour because you're running away from it
and if you run toward me as I throw the
ball it'll approach you more quickly if
you're running at five miles an hour it
might approach you therefore at 105
miles an hour so the point is by virtue
of your motion your speed you can
increase or decrease the speed with
which the ball approaches you as you
measure it when it comes to light
Einstein is saying that is not the case
whether you run toward or away from a
beam of light its speed will be
unchanged when you measure it so let me
show you visually what that would look
like
so it's imagine I've got two characters
George with a laser pointer and Gracie
over here with a device that can measure
the speed of light George fires light
toward her and she measures it and gets
the familiar well-known answer of 300
million meters per second but now let's
do a version of the little experiment
that we described where Gracie is going
to run away or toward George and let's
see what she measures so if she runs
away you think the speech will measure
will be less than 300 million meters per
second but she gets exactly 300 million
meters per second unchanged let's do the
reverse imagine that she run toward
George and as you run toward and you
think that the speed would go up
she'd measure but again she gets exactly
the same answer unchanged constant 300
million meters per second and just in
case you're wondering if it's George
that does the running if he runs toward
Gracie you think the speed she'll
measure goes up but the speed that she
gets for the light beam is again 300
million meters per second and if George
runs away from her you'd think that the
speed of the light shall measure will go
down again
300 million meters per second unchanged
speed of light is constant independent
of the speed of who's getting the light
the receiver who's sending the light the
source the speed of light this measured
is unchanged now that's kind of crazy
how could speed behave that way when it
comes to the speed of light and the
answer is that space and time do not
behave as we would think based on
everyday experience and that is why we
care so much about this result
you